welcome to this video a new video on
middle deemed strategy yeah this series
is mostly about showing demonstrating
strategic ideas and middlegame themes
that you might be able to use in your
own games and maybe remember the kind of
ideas and themes when they come up in
your own game this video is about a
specific type of sacrifice that very
often can be used yeah - to break
passive defences we very often encounter
situations where one side is obviously
better but it's very tough to break
through and very often there you need
something to do something special to
really truly win the game and to convert
the large advantage that you have I have
them selected one example from from our
own practice that I'm going to show you
now it's about positioning rising around
move 30 I will very briefly go through
the start of the game up to this point
just so that you get a feel what's
developed beforehand it's not meant to
be a comprehensive analysis of the game
this was played in 2005 it was a German
league game my opponent Frank Lefkowitz
is a player of master level strength
about 2200 at the time we got him an
opening one of those nameless openings I
believe with d6 and Bishop g4 this is a
pretty decent choice if black just wants
to get a playable game without any big
theoretical workload um one problem with
this defenses that very often you need
to give up your on your bishop pair very
early and this is mostly only three
after g3 black very often takes on f3
but my opponent avoided that
he went with a typical and set up in
them in the center with e5 I didn't
really know how to to combat that at the
time and I'm still not sure now and back
then I was thinking of a plan that at
least gets me the two bishops it's a
closed position so the two bishops are
not super important but still Knight h4
was my was my choice
getting the Knight to f5 and here at
least I'm able to take on his heaven
this is not a great Bishop I know but
still it's two bishops
so this actually happened and they also
get a central superior superiority and
one problem is that this Bishop on g6 is
a really passive piece it looks at the
e4 pawn but it's really not doing that
much I decided after rook e8
to close the center which does not look
or does not seem to be super logical
with two bishops on my side but I was a
bit afraid that he might open up the
center at the right moment to get some
counter play against reform and still is
Bishop on g6 is off side so that's not a
bad choice to keep a long-term advantage
he captured on d5 this surprised me I
remember that because I really welcome
to have an open line I was more
concerned in a way not like afraid but
that he might close everything white is
unquestionably better here because of
the bishop on g6 this very much gives me
additional active ideas like f4 at the
right moment I still have to pawn breaks
sorry about that before and f1 those can
now be combined yes still I think maybe
he should still keep the position close
but he captured on d5 and put the night
on c4 this was certainly the idea but
this night on c5
while looking active it's not a stable
piece long-term I will have before yeah
at the moment efore is is hanging and I
decided to play the somewhat ugly move
f3
but I think this is still a good move it
has some two main ideas my bishop on g2
is not a good piece anyway and that will
relocate in any case it will go to f1 to
play on the Queen side or after h4
Bishop h3 might be used on this diagonal
g2 it's not a great place anyway so I
don't mind they're free and they're free
really covers you form reliably so those
pieces they all they all look at before
but while this is very much covered
right he can play Knight h5 but after
King edge 2 I have this protected g3 so
I'm not weakening my king side that much
note that I have a dark squared Bishop
and he does not so those dark sweat
weaknesses don't matter that much he
went a 5 I've tried to block the Queen
side and I just continued logically g4
is a move that I didn't like to play
that much but I wanted to prevent f5
yeah just make sure he does not get
counter play it's not so clear to me
actually where the point comes where
blacks position becomes becomes very
very bad it's clear that he is passive
and worse but it's not clear where it
sort of gets to the to the point where
he is really really almost losing here
wide is just better but it's not like I
have a direct winning plan
yeah I'm continued here with typical
moves Knight to b5 attacking here and
threatening one c7 and now I'm doubling
on the sefa this was an additional idea
of f3 by the way to get this doubling in
yeah and regard to this position here
it's an interesting moment
here he played the move b6 and this
definitely surprised me I remember that
because I was thinking at the more at
the time well if he goes b6 he's really
weakening the c6 Graham and it was not
yet clear that he needed to play the
move I'm definitely putting some
pressure on c5 but it's not like I'm
threatening to win a pawn or anything he
could have easily delayed this move or
maybe avoided it at all
in the back of my mind I already had
this idea that happens later because
it's so typical of a pawn structure of
that time we would see later what I'm
talking about yeah I went Bishop f1 yeah
this is clear the bishop needs to be on
this diagonal Knight to be 8b3 yeah a
typical procedure white wants to play
before but you don't want to do this
because black can block the whole thing
with a four also this should be quite
okay for why they force a bit expose but
it's not necessary to allow that so I
went for the the slow preparation b3
then a3 then before this is how you do
it normally nine a six a three preparing
before I absolutely need to get rid of
the c5 Knight
this is blocking the C file and
therefore me the only open file that
provides me with some entry squares
Queen d8 rugby to just preparing before
yeah it's a bit difficult maybe B's B
six is definitely something that's
giving ground but I'm not clearly not
quite sure where the point comes where
black is losing ninety seven an
interesting moment I don't exactly
remember my rationale here because I now
captured on c7 it was not a bad move I
mean it keeps a very substantial
advantage for white but now I'm looking
at it and also very much like to just
drop back
serious it keeps the pressure on it does
not exchange any pieces and I still have
before so this is also very good move
maybe even stronger not I'm not totally
sure
well I captured and loops it - of course
he cannot take it's a pin so I'm on the
C file now I have doubled and I
threatened before now yeah black has
only this defense - before really needs
to remove the rook from the C file yeah
rooks III yeah you don't want to go
before as there is some this strange
type of defense we have time rooks III
is a good prep move yeah that avoids
those kind of things and black still is
sort of just sitting around by now it
gets very very critical exactly due to
the thing that happens next I went
before now and takes takes he went to a
four yeah not sure miss is there
something better this I'm invading right
away and well Knight a six it's also
very very ugly I can just go here if
everything else fails yeah he went to a
four Queen e1 and no Knight to d7 yeah
he could try to go here but ultimately
this Knight is um yeah it's sort of
trapped in my camp he can go he can go
like that and now it's gone I will take
it next this isn't something that should
be taken lightly this decision to take
with the dark squared Bishop to take a
piece so the dark squares I exposed but
still white will be upon up and has
and winning chances he went to the seven
yeah
queen is improved queen f2 was also a
good move
no he went night to evade queen f2 and
rook b7 yeah I now found that the queen
is best on f2 here here we come to the
position where because the position that
is the reason why I chose to to show
this game it's quite clear that white
enjoys a good position he has doubled on
the C file the important opened file
it's got two bishops I have a weakness
to attack on b6 d6 is weak yeah so all
this adds up to a substantial wide
advantage but how exactly do you win
it's actually not that easy I mean if
you know the motif it is easy but it can
be very tricky if you try to find some
elaborate maneuver to improve your
position yeah I like cannot triple on
the C far those kind of things in fact
here the solution lies in a sacrifice
right now can break through with the
move loop to c6 using this weaken square
and this is what I hinted at when I said
that I was quite glad to see the move b6
being played because this is a huge help
here for white that I have this entry
square it really is a very typical thing
to happen to have this kind of advance
square in an unopened file where you can
just put a rook and let it take by a
minor piece because the advantages that
you get after the capture are so
enormous in this case in this concrete
case it is it is just flat-out totally
winning if he captures and well he did
take
but here's also a question of what else
very often for the compensation is more
long term here this it is very concrete
in fact after the capture let us briefly
check what happens if he does not
capture of course what I do is I just
attack b6 and he really has no way to
defend it something like this is not
really tough well let's say if he goes
what could you do something like this I
have this move
this is offside threatening Queen a2 and
he really has absolutely no moves now
note that the immediate b5 could be
still answered by getting the knight to
c5 something like this it's not as
convincing yeah rook c6 b5 was the
possibility to keep this pawn on the
board but now what gets Bishop e6 in all
because of the look on the six ranked
Queen moves and the Bishop c7 and now d6
is gone yeah this b5 move really made
this bishop on a form being too totally
out of the game and I'm winning the the
important d6 pawn now yeah he decided to
take at the end but this is now a very
clear win
white takes with the pawn and now this
establishes a multitude of things the
pawn itself is of course dangerous on
the six rank but it also helps with some
other things one thing is that this is
the concrete thing about this position
and I'm directly winning b6 which makes
the wind very clear he cannot really go
anywhere to protect the pawn this is
even worse so he went here and then I
took on b6 though it's too connected
passes which is just enormous
on the other hand very often you have
this kind of both sacrifice for of the
exchange to activate your pieces even
more what it does is after the pawn
shifting from d5 in this case to c6 it
clears the d5 square which very often
can be very useful for pieces just
imagine a knight on d5 would be
fantastic
also Bishop now would be able to go to
this diagonal and have a great position
right in the middle of the board in the
game as mentioned it is even worse as
the b6 pawn is immediately lost Bishop
takes he went here and now b5 those
pawns are simply far far too strong like
when 96 there should be 3 making the
b-pawn freeing the b-pawn to move rook
here and I first activated the bishop
yeah why not the bishop is certainly
nicely placed on d5 went here 55 and now
I'm ready for b6 Black has no way to
stop that he went king e7 b6 and now the
rook is strapped yeah here I expected
resignation but it didn't tell it did
happen he decided to continue after
giving up Luke and for a moment which
was also influenced by my time trouble
yeah it's really not any there's nothing
interesting anymore white is just a
piece up
I am also got this the C part to promote
quickly after we had finished the time
issues he he resigned so it's important
to note and this motif yeah it's the
kind of position where you have an open
file and you have a weak square on the
six rank and very often the way to
proceed is to put a rook on the square
even when it can be
can be captured this is a trait that
gives you a strong pawn on the six rank
a good square that is normally cleared
by the pawn shifting from in this case
d5 to see six and it's a huge space
advantage this really happens a lot in
many em and many games it can be the C
file it can also be another files quite
often it will be the default with a
half-open D file you sometimes have
pawns on let's say e 5 and C 5 and the
weak spot on d6 and you just put the
rook on d6 and let black capture the
rook just to free all your pieces and
establish this fantastic pawn here it
was even yes supported with with
concrete played so if you feel like it's
difficult to breach through such a
passive defense and you have those kind
of weaknesses in the opponent's camp
very often think of an exchange
sacrifice you are putting the rook right
in the opponent's camp block here it's
very difficult to withstand such a
pressure and if the capture is giving
you lots of activity and compensation
it's very often well worth considering
here it is as mentioned a very concrete
win but in many cases it will not be
that concrete but it will sort of help
you transform your advantage and and get
some progress going in the game not
staying in this sort of deadlock when
there's nothing nothing much happening
yeah I hope you enjoyed the video and
got this sort of visualize this motif
that might come up in one of your games
thanks for watching